[موسيقى]
تقول الامثال السويديه التسامح مع الذئب
يعني ظلامه ستلحق بالخروف فكيف اذا كان
الظلم والمهانه يطال خمس البشريه
تنسى الفراشه غالبا انها كانت شرنقه مثل
سويدي فهل يتذكر التائهون ان حالا بذاته
لن يدوم عندما يحترق بيت جارك احضر الماء
الى بيتك ايضا مثل سويدي فهل يدرك
المتغطرسون اننا نعيش في عالم واحد تحت
سماء واحده
لكن
الوقاحه علامه النفس الاكثر خسه يقول
السويديون في امثالهم الشعبيه فهل هناك
وقاحه افضع من اهانه كتاب الله الى
العناوين
من يضع حدا لتجاوزات السويد والدنمارك مع
القران الكريم
علي الصلابي يرد على اساءات نور المالك
للصحابه الكرام
قيس سعيد يلحن في القران
ويغير عدد البقرات في سوره يوسف
قطع روسيا طريق القمح الاوكراني يهدد
اسعار خبز الفقراء
الكوكب يشتعل حرا والجزائر تدفع ثمن حرائق
الاحراز ضحايا
اللغه الفرنسيه مرفوضه في المغرب ولم تعد
رسميه في مالي
مرحبا
السويد في اللغه العربيه
تصغير للسيد فمن لم تكتمل سيادته ونضوجه
يقال له سويد اما السويد الدوله فهي مملكه
اسكندنافيه استندت سياستها الخارجيه طوال
القرن العشرين على مبدا الحياد في الازمات
فما الذي يدفعها اليوم الى ان تكون الازمه
بعينها مع خمس سكان العالم
النظام السويدي يعتبر ان قوانينه تسمح
باهانه مقدسات الامم
ولاجل ذلك وغيره تحتل المرتبه الاولى
عالميا في مؤشر
للديمقراطيه لكنها ديمقراطيه وقوانين تخلت
عنها بلحظه امام طلبي مهاجر سوري ترخيصا
بالتظاهر واحراق الكتابين المقدسين
اليهود والمسيحيين يقول انه قدمه بهدف فتح
خلل المعايير
وازدواجيتها في السويد ولن يحرق ابدا اي
شيء في الاساس سمحوا له بالتظاهر ولم
ياذنوا بحرق الكتابين المقدسين اليهودي
والمسيحي وحسنا فعله لكن هل الحريه
السويديه الالحاديه متخصصه باحراق المصحف
الشريف فقط
وبالعداء للاسلام
وانا بطلبي الموافقه على حرق الكتاب الطلب
اللي انا قدمته وما اجت موافقه على هالشي
للي عم بيقول اني ما في ازدواجيه معايير
يعني انا في لاني ما اجت موافقه نصيه بهذا
الشيء انا نيتي من الاساس ما راح احرق انا
نيتي اني بدي اعمل هاي المظاهره لحتى
افرجي العالم اني المسلمين مثل ما هن
مفكرين احنا كمسلمين ديننا بيفرض علينا
اني نحترم الاخرين لان المسيئه للقران
الكريم عراقي الجنسيه لاجئ في السويد فان
بغداد اشتعلت غضبا امتد الى احراق سفاره
السويد شعبيا وطرد السفيره رسميا وسط
مطالبات
بتسليم الارهابي مونيكا او مونيكا ما بعرف
الى السلطات العراقيه
ليحاكمه بتهمه ازدراء الاديان الازمه
الدبلوماسيه بين العراق والسويد تتصاعد
وقد تمتد الى دول عربيه واسلاميه اخرى
خلفيه تجمع في ستوكهولم شهد دوس لاجئ
عراقي نسخه من المصحف ثم الهجوم على
السفاره السويديه في العراق مئات من انصار
رجل الدين العراقي مقتدى الصدر يقتحمون
السفاره السويديه في بغداد بعد منح السويد
اللاجئ العراقي سلوان موميكا رخصه لحرق
نسخه من المصحف الشريف مجددا وحرق العلم
العراقي هذه المره امام ابواب السفاره
العراقيه في ستوكه الدنمارك بلا صغرى بدل
ان تركز اهتمامها على تربيه الابقار
وانتاج الزبده اطلقت ثيرانا عصابه يبيضيه
متطرفه ومعاديه للاسلام لتحرق بدورها نسخه
من المصحف الشريف في العاصمه كوبنهاجن مع
اهانه العلم العراقي الذي يحمل لفظه
الجلاله اقدمت مجموعتنا دنماركيه يمينيه
متطرفه مناهضه للاسلام على حرق نسخه من
القران الكريم والعالم العراقي امام سفاره
العراق بالعاصمه
يطلب حمايه الحكومه السويديه
لمرافقته الى متجر صاحبه مسلم من اجل شراء
قاروره كوكاكولا اوكي جيت لا اشتري
كوكاكولا من هذا المحل
الشخص قال انت حرقت قران ما نبيع لك
وانا بدون حمايه لربما يمكن يتهجم عليه
يمكن وش يصير هذا الارهابي الملحد الخائن
لوطنه والسلم الاهلي اختار تاجرا مسلما
دون غيره لاثاره المزيد من الشغب طبعا
المسلمون لا يتعاملوا مع من احرق كتاب
الله الكريم فهو لن يتورع عن احراق
متاجرهم وبيوتهم اذا سنحت له الفرصه الرد
على مونيكا جاءه من مواطنه العراقي
المسيحي الذي صوطف وجوده في المتجر
ما يهمك ما تقول
ما يهمني انا اجيت اشتري قال لي ما ابيع
لك
على ملك ملك علاقات
كلها وحتى
عراقيه تتخلى عن جنسيتها الثانيه السويديه
فتحرق جواز سفرها وتقطع بانها لن تعود الى
السويد في حياتها
بعد ارجع وهذا جوازكم مثل ما تشوفون ريحه
الريفيه مثل ما حرقت قراننا الله يحرق
قلبكم وزير الخارجيه التركيه كان فيدان
دعا العالم الاسلامي الى رد منظم على
الاساءات للقران الكريم الشعوب المسلمه
تعور على تركيا كما ذكرنا في حلقه سابقه
في وضع حد لتحدي السويد مشاعر الامه من
خلال اقفال انقره بابا انضمام السويد الى
حلف الناتو خصوصا بعد ان توعد الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان برد قوي على احراق المصحف
الشريف في السويد عرض بعد ذلك على الغرب
مقايضه ضم السويد الى الناتو بادخال تركيا
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي لقد تم تحديد
الخطوات المتبادله التي يت اتخاذها فيما
يتعلق بعضويه السويد في حلف الناتو من
خلال بيان مشترك وبمجرد افتتاح برلمانينا
سنقوم بدورنا ولا نشك في ان نوابنا
سيفعلون ما تمليه عليهم مصالح بلادنا بما
يتماشى مع ضمائرهم مع استمراره في تبريد
مشاكل بلاده في كل الاتجاهات التقى الرئيس
اردوغان في انقره الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود
عباس وجمعه برئيس حماس اسماعيل هنيه كما
يلتقي رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو فماذا عند نتنياهو المفتوحه شهيته
على دماء الفلسطينيين في نابلس وفي جنين
ليقدمه للاخرين وهو الا هم له الان
الافلات من العقاب والسجن في تل ابيب التي
اشتعلت غضبا عليه بعد مصادقه الكنيسه على
تعديلاته القضائيه
سنوات الاخيره والازمه هذه حدتها تتصاعد
يوم الاخر ونهايتها بشكل او باخر متوقعه
لكل من يعني له درايه في في العلوم
السياسيه وفي القانون الدستوري الاسرائيلي
لب الموضوع هو كون رئيس الحكومه شخصيه
متهمه بثلاث قبائل جنائيه قضايا فساد مهمه
وهو موجود في راس الهرم السلطوي ويحاول ان
يغير كل قوانين الدوله وكل انظمه الدوله
الدستوريه والنظاميه من اجل انقاذ نفسه من
من الدخول ومن وراء القضبان فهضم والشارع
الاسرائي يشتعل
اشهر طويله من الاحتجاجات لم تشهد درجه
العنف التي حدثت ليلى الاثنين الشرطه
الاسرائيليه فرقت المحتجين بالعنف
الاف الاسرائيليين احتلوا الشوارع وقطعوا
الطرقات السريعه خصوصا في القدس وتل ابيب
اعترادا على اقرار الكنيست للقانون الاول
من خطه التعديلات القضائيه التي تسعى
حكومه نتنياهو الى تنفيذها والتي يحتاجون
ضدها منذ اشهر في حيفا مارس المستوطنون
الاسرائيليون المتشددون عادتهم في
الاعتداء على دير مار الياس والكاهن
مكاريوس جوريوس يؤكد استعداد المسيحيين
للتضحيه بارواحهم من اجل حمايه مقدساتهم
لانه في كل محل بدهم يسيطروا عليه ويعملوا
يهودي في هاي البلاد بدعوا ان هناك في قبر
بالرغم من انه هناك ما فيش ولا اي اثر لاي
شيء من اللي بدعه حتى لو ادى ذلك بان نقدم
شهاده الدم لن نتنازل عن مقدساتنا لانها
ابعد من حجر البوليس لما بيجي لهنا
حضرتهن يضربوا الكنيسه اللي هن بدهن
يعتدوا على الكنيسه
عم بحاربوا الاسلام زهقوا من الاسلام
اسئلوا للمسيحيه اللي شايفينو احنا انه
حضرتك وكرمتنا
[موسيقى]
دهش المواطلون في بنغازي بليبيا من تجوال
اسد غضنفر في شوارع المدينه الساحليه
محمولا على متن سياره تويوتا للدفع
الرباعي ليشاهده الصغار والكبار ويسخر منه
بعض المتطفلين سياره التويوتا ذكرت البعض
بتسعه الاف سياره دفع رباعي من ماركه
تويوتا اشتراها نور المالكي بحسب التقارير
عندما كان رئيسا لوزراء العراق وانتقلت
بقدره قادر الى حوزه تنظيم داعش ابان
سيطرته على البوصله قبل اقل من عشر سنوات
اما مشهد الاسد الذي لا حول له ولا قوه
على المتطاولين فقد ذكر اخرين بالصحابي
الجليل القائد الاسلامي الكبير عمرو بن
العاص رضي الله عنه وهو في ضريحه بينما
يشتمه المالكي على الشاشات ويشتم غيره من
الصحابه الكرام بلغه تجافي طبقه رجال
الدوله الذين يؤخذ بكلامهم وعلى كلامهم
ويتجنبون اثاره الفتن بين ابناء الشعب
العراقي الموحد بكل اطيافه في مكافحه
الفساد والدفاع عن المقدسات يعلق صحفي
عراقي اثر رئيس الوزراء العراقي الاسبق
نور المالكي جدلا وانتقادات واسعه على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بعد شتمه لصحابي
عمرو بن العاص حفل الاسبوع بردود علميه
وتاريخيه عديده على المالك برزت منها
مطالعه للشيخ الدكتور علي الصلابي فندى
فيها مغالطات دور المالك في موازين العلم
وقواعد الانصاف والعقل الخلاصه عمرو بن
العاص رضي الله عنه ليس معصوما عن الخطا
لكن اخطاء الفاتحين لا يناقشها نور
المالكي حارس مرمى احذيه المحتلين يعلق
شيخ ازهري
تحذر القصيده الخاقانيه من اللحن في
القران الكريم وتقول فاول علم الذكر اتقان
حفظه ومعرفه باللحن من فيك اذ يجري اللحن
في لغه العرب له عده معان وعندما يطلق على
قراءه احدهم للقران الكريم
فيقصد منه الخطا والانحراف والبيل عن
الصواب ونحن في القران الكريم نوعان جلي
وخفي الجلي هو الواضح وهو حرام باجماع
علماء الدين الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد
تكررت اخطاؤه في تلاوه القران الكريم على
الملا اخرها ونامل ان تكون اخيرتها لم
يحرف فيها حرفا واحدا بل كلمه كامله فغير
سبع بقرات الى تسع بق رات في الايه
السادسه والاربعين من سوره يوسف اثناء
خطابه امام منظمه الفاو الدوليه فقد جاء
في القران الكريم
يوسف
ايها الصديق
افتنا في تسع بقرات سمان
ياكلنهن سبع اعجاب
والصبر والسنبلات
خضرا
واخرى يابسه
[موسيقى]
ان اقرا امامكم
ما قاله الشاعر الايطالي
سارجي
باللغه الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
اوروبا دايت برنامج يفرضه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين على القاره العجوز لكنه
يطال كل العالم من خلال قطع طريق القمح
الاوكرانيه عنها فخبز القمح المعدل مضر
يقول خبراء فيما تقول الحكومات الغربيه ان
بوتين هو المضر بعد قراره عدم تمديد
اتفاقيه الحبوب المبرمه مع اوكرانيا
برعايه الامم المتحده وتركيا لكنه قرار
قابل للتعديل اذا التزم الغرب بشروط بوتين
امام التهديدات الروسيه واعتبار اي سفينه
شحن اوكرانيه في البحر الاسود هدفا عسكريا
تحاول اوكرانيا ايجاد حل لتصدير الحبوب
خاصه الى دول الشرقيه التي تدفع ثمن
تضامنها مع كييف
اذا استعدوا ايها الفقراء
اسعار الخبز اينما كنتم في هذا العالم
المضطرب الذي يتحكم به الحكام النوويون
منظمه هيومن رايت اصبح الامن الغذائي
العالمي في خطر بعد ان علقت روسيا العمل
بمبادره الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود مع
اوكرانيا سترتفع اسعار القمح في جميع
انحاء العالم في حضاره عالم عائم على
ترسانات اسلحه الدمار الشامل والموت يخشى
على الخبز وكل ضرورات الحياه الكهرباء
مقطوعه عن نحو 700 مليون انسان حول العالم
كما تفيد الامم المتحده ما هي حصه العرب
منهم وهل نحتاج الى الضوء اصلا ام ان نور
اصحاب السياده والمعالي يكفينا
وزير الكهرباء المصري محمد شاكر يعلن انه
اقفل تكييف بيته ليشعر مع المصريين الذين
يعانون من انقطاع الكهرباء المتكرر عن
معظم الجمهوريه الا عن بيت الوزير وانما
في لزوم ابدا يطفي المكيف اذا الكهرباء
مطفيه كهرباء يا جماعه امبارح النهارده
اول امبارح كان يوم اللي فاتوا في انقطاع
كهرباء في مناطق كتيره طب دي واحده طلعت
قالت مصر منوره باهلها والصهاينه منورين
بالغاز بتاعنا البنت رفعت اليافطه دي بس
بس
في ثواني كانت ورا الشمس في لهيب الصيف
الحارق هذا العام لو ان الكهرباء والتكييف
موجودان لسكتت الفتاه وبقيت في بيت اهلها
واذا طال غياب التكييف فسيعود الكثيرون من
الازواج الى بيت اهلهم مع فقط الطلاق بحسب
ملاحظه اعلاميا مصري التكييف مهم في
حياتنا الخاصه واحنا قاعدين في البيت لو
انت جايب تكييف والجو كده كان فيه رطوبه
وحر زي اليومين دول ده يبرد اعصابك لكن
اعصابك لما تبقى شيطه كده لا ممكن بقول لك
كانت نسب الطلاق ارتفعت اذن موجه تحر
عالميه تضرب في كل الاتجاهات وتخلف ضحايا
في بعض الدول كان مشهدها الاقصى عربيا ما
حدث في الجزائر مع وفاه واصابه عشرات
المواطنين بحرائق الغابات في شمال البلاد
تعلم وزاره الداخليه والجماعه المحليه
والتهيئه العمرانيه انه تم تسجيل عشره
ضحايا من افراد الجيش الوطني الشعبي 9
ضحايا مدنيين لترتفع بذلك حصيله ضحايا هذه
الحرائق الى 34 حاله وفاه رحمهم الله
فرنسا التي لم تغير بعد خطابها الذي يعتبر
ان الاسلام يعيش ازمه في كل مكان تلقت
صفعه من دوله مالي مع اقتراب الذكرى
السنويه الاولى لطرد اخر جندي فرنسي من
بلادها فقرر الحاكم العسكري المؤقت اسيمي
جويته ضمن الدستور الجديد لمالي تخفيضا
اللغه الفرنسيه الى الدرجه الثانيه فلم
تعد لغه رسميه بل لغه عمل لحين التخلي
عنها بشكل نهائي حيث اقبال الشعب المالي
المسلم متزايد على تعلم اللغه العربيه
وعلوم القران الكريم
وفي المغرب رفض رواد السينما مجرد دبلجه
في المين جديدين باللغه الفرنسيه
وقاطعوا حفلات العرض في قاعات السينما في
اوروبا عندما تتحدث اليوم عن قمع الشرطه
لحريه التظاهر والتعبير فان الحقوقيين
يشيرون فورا الى فرنسا فهل تتحول شوارع
باريس الى متاريس بين الشعب وعسكر النظام
الهيئات الدوليه تحذر منظمه العفو ودوريه
الحكومه الفرنسيه الى اصلاح قواعد الشرطه
المتعلقه باستخدام الاسلحه النازيه والقوه
المميته ومحاربه ما اسمته التمييز
العنصريه المنهج في تطبيق القانون في
المتفرقات يروى عن السيد المسيح عليه
السلام انه قال اذا فسد الملح فبماذا يملح
جمعيه قريه المحبه والسلام في لبنان لا
محبه فيها ولا سلام
تدعي رعايه اطفال اللبنانيين وسوريين
باعمار مختلفه
اقفلتها السلطات لاقدامها على بيع الاطفال
والتحرش الجنسي وغيرهم من الجرائم
باسراف مديره الجمعيه نورما سعيد بحسب
التقارير
التحرش الاعتداء الجنسي الاتجار بالبشر
تظهر الى العلم بقوه في الاونه الاخيره
واخر فصولها اقفال جمعيه قريه المحبه
والسلام بالشمع الاحمر ارغام القصه على
ممارسه الجنس وتعاطي المخدرات ما دفع
باحداهن الى محاوله انهاء حياتها اتخذنا
القاصرات على النايت كلوبز وبتسهرهم
وبتشربهم وفي وحده منهم جربت تنتحر مديره
الجمعيه زورت اوراق طفل باعت اذا فينا
نقول عطيه هذا الولد لعيله لقاء بدل ماده
في ليبيا الطاقه رئيس حكومه الوفاق عبد
الحميد الدبيبه ممثلا دراميا جسد دوره في
مسلسل تلفزيونيا محلي فنظر اليه وسال
الحاضرين تواني شين انا هالقد بشع اعتبر
الليبيون كلمه بيبا تنمرا غير مسؤول من
مسؤول فيما راى اخرون انها مزحه خفيفه
وردوا عليه توا الممثل امر مصور بالمقارنه
معك لا لا
انت اللي
مثلت الحريه
[تصفيق]
يا جماعه
[موسيقى]
ختاما اذا كنت عاشقا عتيقا لقهوه البن
ستذوب مشاعرك في طعمها العميق وعطرها
الاسر ودفئها الحميم هذه اقانيم تتقدم
باصوات بعيده على الوعاء الذي سيحتوي
قهوتك المحبوبه اكان زجاجيا او حتى من
الكريستال او البلاستيك او الكرتون
فلماذا نبذل اعمارنا سعيا وراء اجمل
الاغلفه وافخارها لدنيانا ونغفل عن تجويد
جوهر حياتنا الذي لا يشبه احيانا شيئا من
قهوتنا الا في لونها القاتم
الى اللقاء
فظلام ثم نور وحياه
[موسيقى]
ان اراد الله شيئا قال
فهو يكون
[موسيقى]